it's my pleasure to welcome you here
today to the first of our company and
scholars lectures for this year we've
got quite a
of talks starting off with a real treat
today by John Jian Coppola
professor token professor with economics
a topic that is a great public concern
that is the financial crisis that's been
gripping the world for the last few
years John is it turns out to be a
faculty Brett era at Yale has his dad
was a professor here and here I was an
undergraduate math major but Harvard to
get a PhD at econ and came back to the
faculty in 1980 he spent very busy since
then I marvel at all the things he does
in addition to being a professor of
economics he's held important positions
concurrently in in business such as
co-founding the Ellington
capital management firm which he serves
as a partner to this day he has founded
a Hellenic Studies program here at Yale
a dream that his dad always had but was
not fulfilled but John arranged for the
financing of this thing and has been
helping to run it he is the father of a
Yale freshman cell this third generation
galas here in this family and I know
he's very proud of that
outside of Yale he's received some very
important hunters such as election of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences he's received it Sloan
fellowships and some other awards in the
field of economics today is going to
talk about the role the leverage cycle
in the current financial crisis and
before I invite John to the podium I'd
like to invite you to come to our the
rest of our company of scholars lectures
the next one is going to be on December
13th Laurie Santos from the psychology
department it's going to talk about the
evolution of irrational behavior from
her studies on monkeys
in January and April we're going to have
two additional lectures that I'll tell
you more about in December so John thank
you for joining us and if any of you
want to see this again it's gonna be on
YouTube in a couple of days so thank you
Tom it's a pleasure to be here my
father's office was actually upstairs in
the 40 years and the hall of graduates
tattoo off after he retired he got a
little office but anyway he had an
office up on the third floor here and so
nice to be back here so I'm gonna try
and give a narrative of what the cause
of the crisis that's as Tom said is
gripped America and now the rest of the
world for the last four or five years
and you know any big event like that has
many causes and many explanations I'm
gonna focus on one I think you know you
know you have a good explanation when
one suffices and you don't need ten
others but you can decide for yourself
at the end whether this one really
suffices but it's going to be the
leverage cycle I call it and the
leverage cycle is a word that leverage
that never appears in academic economics
almost no macroeconomic textbook will
ever mention leverage or endogenous
leverage or it just isn't a concept that
the profession has worked with now on
Wall Street they talk about leverage all
the time and I got the idea for this
when I was when I was on Wall Street
actually I in nineteen I was I'm a
mathematical economist so I'm supposed
to be the most out of touch person with
the world in the Economics Department
but I decided I was so out of touch
maybe I should go to Wall Street for a
year in 1989 and I visited a firm called
Kidder Peabody which turned out to be
the small investment bank number seven
or something investment bank but it
turned out to be the biggest player in
the next few years in the mortgage
market so I began to think about
collateral and mortgages and then Kidder
Peabody went out of business in 1994
after 135 years five years after I
got associated with the place uh I
remember inviting a bunch of people I
had arranged for the firm to hire in the
research department 75 of them and I
told them that they were fired and then
I went dork next door to the office next
to mine and the guy said you're fired
and so six thousand people got fired so
I began to think about what that might
have what might have caused it but then
a bunch of us founded a hedge fund
called Ellington Capital Management and
in 1998 when long-term capital you may
have heard of it it's a famous hedge
fund nearly went on went out of business
we nearly went out of business as a
result of them nearly going out of
business and so that was twice in five
years that something disastrous had
happened and nearly happened and that's
still around now so we survived and had
better days but I began to think then
that something must be systemic and
something this yeah I couldn't have done
it so badly so wrong twice in a row got
all this happened to me it must be
something in the world that's going on
so that's when I developed the leverage
cycle and as I'll try to show the
current crisis fits the story even
better than the other two that prompted
me to think about it so so I'm gonna
give a narrative that's missing from
macroeconomics and missing from the the
current administration I think one of
the problems the current administration
has in galvanizing support for any of
their actions is there's no coherent
story of what caused everything and what
we're supposed to do about it and that's
why it's hard to marshal support so I'm
gonna tell you the theory right at the
beginning and then gradually build it up
so that you know what's coming so
basically the idea is that there's a
long period of low volatility and
financial innovation and those increase
leverage ok now leverage means how much
the the size of the loan relative to the
value of the collateral so this is all
about collateral and the loan-to-value
ratio that's what leverage means
loan-to-value ratio it's a ratio so if
you have $100 house can you borrow $90
on it or $10 on it or $50 on it so a
variable as I said that's gonna be
central to my explanation but is almost
entirely absent from any economic theory
so so what I think happens is there's a
long period of low volatility and time
enough for there to be a lot of
financial innovation those two things
low volatility and financial innovation
increase leverage now the big surprise
the big point of a theory is that
increased leverage means increase asset
prices so the collateral the the assets
used to be priced here people could
borrow this amount then leverage goes up
they can buy a higher percentage and the
fact that the leverage goes up raises
the prices of the assets and still the
percentage stays very high so the amount
borrowed is going up for two reasons the
percentage of the assets borrowed is
going up and the asset prices themselves
are going up so it's a sort of squared
effect so there's a huge amount of extra
borrowing and at that point as we'll see
the economy comes very vulnerable so if
there's a thing called what I call scary
bad news it's not just bad but scary
that causes people to reduce the amount
they're willing to lend and so the new
leverage goes way down the old borrowing
though is still up here the old debts
are way up here so the asset prices
because new leverage Falls the asset
prices collapse down to here and what
you end up with is a big gap between
what's owed and what the values of the
assets are that back the promises so
that discrepancy huge debt and low asset
values that's the situation we're in now
and that's a catastrophe as I'm going to
explain and really the only way out of
the problem is to forgive some of the
debt you're not gonna get it paid back
anyway you should forgive some of it so
that's the story I'm going to tell and
try to develop and of course we haven't
been able to forgive the debt so if you
believe this story one of the main
implications is that the Federal Reserve
is not concentrating on the right thing
they spend all their time worrying about
the interest rate whenever anything goes
wrong the Federal Reserve's supposed to
lower the interest rates the economists
call forth the newspapers call for it
the public calls for it interest rate
interest rate interest rate well when
things went wrong in 2008 they lowered
the interest rate to zero it didn't
solve the problem it's because the
interest rate wasn't the heart of the
problem it usually isn't the heart of
the problem
it's the collateral or the leverage
that's the heart of the problem that's
what I'm trying to argue so the Fed
ought to be managing leverage not
managing interest rates if you believe
what I'm saying so the macroeconomists
didn't predict the crisis not one of
them really predicted the crisis not
Greenspan who's in charge of the Federal
Reserve not Bernanke who was in charge
after a Greenspan and before the crisis
he didn't predict the crisis not the
head of bush's economic team not the
head of the Obama economic team not Paul
Krugman none of them foresaw or
predicted you know not even Krugman
foresaw the crisis or if he for if he
thought something was wrong his
attention was entirely on global
problems and not on your mortgages and
in collateral so the models that all
these people use to predict the effect
of policy is just missing what I claim
is going to be essential so you know you
remember that they didn't even after the
crisis started they thought that their
stimulus you remember the Obama stimulus
was gonna solve the problem Christina
Romer famously said unemployment would
never get above 8% you know a few months
later it hit 10% so there was something
wrong with their economic models the
models are all based on shocks to
technology or to the expectations of
technology but they don't they don't
have the scary kind of shock I'm talking
about the one that increases uncertainty
they just have shocks that are bad not
shocks that are bad and increase
uncertainty so even after the fact they
don't explain what are the precise
things that happen in the world that
triggered the crisis what are the events
that really start it all off so so I
have a burden of trying to tell you what
those are so the models that the Fed
uses there are no changes in leverage no
changes in the likelihood of default
there's really not default in the models
at all anyway there's no allowance for
people being underwater or indebted and
there's no mention of financial
innovation all those things are missing
from the economic models okay so that's
what I want to show you how to add and
how it explains what happened now this
is hardly a new idea what I'm saying the
idea of leverage and collateral in fact
I would say that Shakespeare had to say
idea 400 years ago though he isn't given
much credit for it now the reading of a
play The Merchant of Venice is like the
reading of the economy you know there
are many ways of reading it and all of
them are no doubt valid so but I I
believe there's a correct way of leading
it and I'll mention that at Yale there's
a I've sat in a class I've been lucky to
sit in a class on Shakespeare taught for
faculty this semester with some people
who are in this room and we read The
Merchant of Venice and so the
understanding of the the everybody else
is quite different from my understanding
so the sort of Yale understanding is
that it's a story and a comedy and
Bassanio who was trying to woo Portia he
reveals himself little by little to be a
bigger and bigger fool and as as Harold
Bloom says you know he wouldn't they
marry at the end and Harold Bloom says
he wouldn't give the marriage six months
because Portia is so wonderful and
Bassanio such a fool but I and it's it's
about anti-semitism so those are the two
that's all the two standard readings of
the play and I don't want to say they're
wrong there's just alternative readings
I think The Merchant of Venice is about
the leverage cycle so why is that well
you may remember that well in fact I'll
start with how the play begins the play
begins with Antonio who's the Merchant
of Venice walking on stage and he says
forsooth I know not why I'm so sad and
the other guy says well of course you're
sad I mean you must be really nervous
because all your boats are on the ocean
they're a tremendous risk and he says no
I'm not worried about that
every boats on the different ocean so
I'm not worried about that and then they
say well it must be that you're worried
about love and he said no love's not it
either
so you see Shakespeare at the very
beginning has said it's business first
and love second
Annie understands diversification so you
the plot of the play is that Antonio his
friend Bassanio needs to woo this
wonderful woman Portia the first thing
you find out about Portia is not that
she's beautiful she's rich and Bassanio
the first thing you find out about
Bassanio is he as a theory of how to
invest which I won't bother to tell you
but that's how he's introduced with this
theory of how to invest so Bassanio
needs to cast another arrow like he did
the first one and by finding the second
finding also the first at this theory of
investment he wants to borrow the money
but his friend Antonio doesn't have
enough money so they go to [ __ ] to
borrow the money and Toni owes money is
all you know invested in the ships so
they go to Antonio and they Haegele over
the loan and there's a long conversation
about what the loan should be and what
the interest rate should be in fact
there's pages of discussion and that's
the beginning of the anti-semitism
because Antonio says no Christian would
ever charge interest and [ __ ] says
look don't you understand this is a
matter of your impatience and my
patience Bassanio is has the right one
Antonio has the right wants of his
friends Bassanio the impatient Bassanio
needs the money and [ __ ] patience is
the bad is the patience is the badge of
my tribe he's a patient guy and so
that's why he's willing to lend and the
other guy Bassanio and Antonio are
willing to borrow in fact the modern
theory of interest and is a Yale
professor named Irving Fisher developed
it and it's called the impatience theory
of interest so Shakespeare already
understood the impatience theory of
interest and [ __ ] understood it 400
years ago but they don't just negotiate
the interest rate they know should
negotiate the collateral and I ask you
if you're not from the English even if
you are from the English department
almost nobody can say what was the rate
of interest that [ __ ] actually
charged Bassanio and Antonio they can't
remember because it seems so unimportant
Shakespeare made the more important
thing the more dramatic the pound of
flesh collateral so Shakespeare
understood collateral is important
interest less important memorable
collateral forgettable interest rate so
then what happens the boats all
apparently sink they can't repay the
loan
and so Porsche disguises herself as the
judge and tries to rule what should
happen and [ __ ] says it's the
contract we have a contract I want my
pound of flesh that's what's in the
contract and the others asked for mercy
and Porsche says it's critical to the
Commerce of Venice the most commercial
of cities that we enforce contracts the
state has an interest in forcing
contracts but sometimes you shouldn't
enforce the contract sometimes it's the
interest of the state the regulatory
body to change the contract so what do
they change do they change the 3,000
ducats to a different amount what do
they change they change the collateral a
pound of flesh but not a drop of blood
and so the regulatory body should be
managing and changing the collateral not
the interest rate which she doesn't
change at all so that's the now that
that could have been the end of the play
but it has one more dramatic scene by
the way the whole things about investing
and I'll just mention one other reason
why you know it's about investing how
does Bassanio win Porsche he has to pick
the right casket and their three caskets
of to choose gold silver and LED or
something and her pictures in one then
you marry her and if you picked the
wrong one you have to sign a contract
saying you can't marry anybody not her
not anybody else so this is sort of left
out on the play on Broadway and all the
introductory speeches the people who
choose they get left out so what happens
is most of the suitors get so nervous
that it's so dangerous to you know one
such a risk they don't want to pick at
all so of course her father who set this
all up wants a husband for his wonderful
daughter who's got the nerve and the
courage to make a choice like that but
more importantly each of them begins
their speeches by saying it's incredibly
risky I wouldn't do this unless I was
getting an incredibly high return so
risk and return Shakespeare's explaining
always come together you don't do
something risky unless you can get a
high rate of return so that's the reason
for the three caskets and Sanyal picks
the right casket so anyway when he picks
the right casket and in Windsor and she
clearly is in love with him and wants
him to win she gives him her ring and
says never give up this ring and he
swears never to give it up so after the
court scene he goes up to her not
realizing a pterence is a wonderful
judge you judge
so well and so fairly I'm so grateful
let me give you a gift you freed my
friend Antonio who I thought was gonna
die and she says I don't need a gift he
says no no I insist and she says well
how about that ring you're wearing and
he says no I can't come to the ring I
promised my my wife Portia I'd never
give up that ring and she says you want
to make me a gift that's what I want so
he says ok and he gives her the ring and
that's how you're supposed to figure out
that he's a fool and there's another
scene where that's repeated with the
rings and and there was another ring
with [ __ ] who had never have given up
his ring anyway the ring thing gets
repeated many times but what's the point
of it the final point of the play most
famous speech in the play is Portia as
judge says [ __ ] show mercy don't you
know the quality of mercy drop us from
the heaven blah blah blah blah blah blah
it helps him who gives and him who
receives he refuses to show mercy he
wants the contract enforced so Bassanio
understands mercy he understands when
circumstances change and unexpected
things happen and the promise he made in
good faith before to her no longer is
fitting because some unexpected thing
has happened the ring is more useful to
give to the judge than to give back to
her he gives it to the judge so you
shouldn't always keep your promise the
message of the play is mercy and keeping
your promise is not always the right
thing to do it helps him in unexpected
and dire circumstances he'll help to
break a promise and for the lender to
show mercy helps him who shows the mercy
and him who receives it and so [ __ ]
and the Merchant of Venice I think is
all about the leverage cycle about
collateral more important than interest
rate and forgiveness at the end when the
debt is too high to pay and that's what
my theme is gonna be ok so I've
developed this I've developed this over
many years starting in 97 in 2003 and I
only mention this because that's before
the current crisis ok and so now other
people like even Ben Bernanke early on
wrote about the depression and he wrote
he uses he mentions collateral but he
never talks about the change in the
ratio of the debt to the collateral and
that's the crucial thing in the same
house with the same value can borrow
more now recently everybody's talking
about leverage ok so as I said to remind
you what it means collateral is
something you put up to back
like a house no recourse means if if you
don't pay they can take your house but
other than that you're free so if you
have a hundred dollar house and someone
burrows 80 the loan-to-value ratio is
eighty percent the margin or haircut or
down payment is 20 percent and leverage
is called five because with twenty
dollars you've got to use twenty dollars
of cash and you leveraged it up to be
able to buy a hundred dollar asset so
all those things are ratios meaning the
same thing twenty percent eighty percent
five they all describe the same
situation so I'll use them
interchangeably so leverage as I say is
different on new loans remember my story
is going to be the price of prices go
way up and now uh now when the asset
prices fall the new borrowers are gonna
borrow at an incredibly small ratio but
the old borrowers the old debts are
still up here and the assets are way
down here so on the old loans the loan
is still that high but the asset is
worth much less so the leverage goes
above a hundred percent so on this
confusion in many economists but anyway
so it the old leverage goes up but the
new leverage falls before the crisis
okay so anyway so in standard economic
theory you don't have leverage you have
supply and demand that's one equation
determining one variable the interest
rate so in my theory the reason I
started with this is an impure Lee
intellectual puzzle how could one
equation supply equals demand determine
two variables the interest rate and the
leverage so I don't have time to explain
it but it turns out there are many
equations and so more complicated than
it seems but anyway that's what I worked
out the theory of equity briam leverage
as well as iquilibrium interest rates
and previously people had just fixed the
leverage or ignored it altogether so
what in the theory determines the
interest rate well it's in patience
that's Irving Fisher and Shakespeare and
[ __ ] they all had that figured out
four hundred years ago but the leverage
is determined by two things by
uncertainty and over the future value of
the collateral the nervous lender is not
going to loan 99 dollars on a hundred
dollar house if he thinks the price of
the house might fall if the if he's
convinced that the price of the house is
rock solid or can only go up he'll lend
a much higher percentage of it so it's
the volatility of the collateral prices
that's determining what fraction the
lender will let you have and then and
you know so it's a worry about default
and second
we there's financial innovation so why
is financial innovation so important to
leverage because making promises is the
heart of economics it's the heart of
life basically and to make a promise you
have to put up collateral you have to
show you're gonna pay it back there's
not very much useful collateral houses
are the most useful collateral so
knowing that collateral is so scarce and
so valuable the financial system finds
way of stretching it so ever most of all
the innovation on Wall Street you can
understand as figuring clever ways of
stretching the collateral you tranche
promises so the same prompt the same
house backs many different promises you
pyramid promises so I use a house to
make a promise and then someone else
uses my promise to make as collateral
for his promise so the house is
basically back to promises so those
innovations are ways of stretching the
collateral so they increase leverage so
now why is leverage important so every
trader as I said economists didn't pay
much attention to it but the traders
would say it's important because of two
reasons first the sensitivity if you if
you buy a house by putting twenty
dollars of cash down and borrow 80 for
the hundred dollar house and the house
falls to 99 dollars well if you
eventually sell the house at 99 the
house has gone down by 1% in value but
you have to still pay back your 80s
you're left with 19 out of your 20
you've lost 5% of your capital so being
leveraged 5 to 1 means your sensitivity
is 5 times as large that's why many
people say we should prevent banks from
leveraging so they're not so sensitive
to the change in asset prices so that's
certainly true and certainly important
and that was always something I talked
about I mean other people talked about
it before me that's the famous thing
about leverage they also say that you
know there's no recourse collateral
that's dangerous because people can just
walk away from their collateral that
falls in value so those are the two
things they said about people on Wall
Street would tell you about leverage but
the thing that I think I contributed in
the 1990s was the idea that leverage
explains asset prices going up and that
I think is the most important
consequence of leverage it explains
bubbles so why should that be so more
leverage means higher asset prices and
low leverage means lower ass
prices so why if there's no short sales
which are gonna come back to so why
should that be well I imagine this is
all common sense a world where people
from top to bottom the people have
different willingness to pay for the
asset so the people at the top are
willing to pay a lot people at the
bottom are willing to pay much less now
why do people differ and how much
they're willing to pay well
people at the top maybe they're more
risk tolerant than the people at the
bottom that's why they're willing to pay
more
maybe it's houses we're talking about
and they'd like to live in the houses
more maybe they're using the asset for
productive reasons and they they're more
skillful so they're willing to pay more
for it or maybe they're more optimistic
about the future there are many reasons
why peak some people are willing to pay
more than others so what's going to
happen what's gonna happen is there's
gonna be a price and the price will be a
certain level and people who think it's
worth more than the price they're gonna
want to buy the asset the people think
the price is too low they're gonna I
mean too high there their valuations
lower they're gonna want to sell the
asset so many people will sell it
there'll be some people buying it and I
call those the natural buyers now the
the guy who's just indifferent the
marginal buyer we economists call it
he's indifferent he thinks the price is
fair or another way of saying it is his
opinion is setting the price now what
happens when there's more leverage when
there's more leverage you can borrow
more on the house so the people up here
instead of growing 50 dollars in the
house they can borrow 90 dollars on the
house
so many people were optimistic who
didn't have 50 dollars to put down but
they've got 10 to put down they can now
buy the house or people can buy more
than one house so these natural buyers
who before you needed a lot of them to
buy the houses now many fewer of them
are able to buy the same number of
houses because each one of them with the
same cash can borrow more and buy more
of the houses so the marginal buyer
increases so the marginal buyer instead
of being here he goes up to here so
fewer buyers are buying the assets but
the marginal buyer being higher means
the price is now equal to what he thinks
it's worth so the price has gone up
simply because the people to top could
borrow more and not because the interest
rate changed or not because the house is
more valuable or anything simply because
people borrow more so that's it that's
the common sensical story of leverage
that I'm trying to tell leverage raises
asset prices
okay so now these people down here since
they're not buying they have no reason
to borrow in fact they're gonna be the
lenders so the increase in leverage is
asymmetric it helps the borrowers and
buyers it doesn't do anything they can
just stand by in shock and amazement
that the price is so high so so what's
the the cycle the crash so when there's
this long period of low volatility as I
say the lenders aren't very nervous so
they're willing to leverage because
there's low volatility but also
innovation is gradually increasing and
the innovation is you know all the stuff
I was doing a Kidder Peabody and
everything that was happening on Wall
Street the great mortgage powerhouses
there they were
that was good securitization in those
days that was stretching the amount of
collateral and increasing leverage - so
the optimists acquire more and more the
assets the asset prices go up but that
sets the stage for the crash so why is
that well the same thing always happens
in these leverage cycle crashes there's
bad news okay that makes everybody think
the assets are worth less but the bad
news is scary that's the critical thing
creating more uncertainty now what do I
mean by scary bad news even if it's not
very bad if you're at an airport and
somebody says and they make an
announcement the plane is gonna be 10
minutes late well that's nothing who
cares if the plane is 10 minutes late
the trouble is once they tell you it's
10 minutes late
everybody thinks oh my gosh they're
gonna tell us in a few minutes that it's
gonna be 20 minutes late and then I'm
gonna miss my connection then I don't
have to give my talk at Yale and then
it's gonna be incredible don't be
incredibly pissed at me and that you
know it'll be a real disaster so then I
start to try then you start to try and
make other plans and everything gets
screwed up so a little bit of scary bad
news can change the way people act in
particular the scary part of the bad
news is going to make the lenders reduce
leverage there's some they're suddenly
gonna stop asking it's gonna create
higher volatility and the lenders are
gonna know in the new loans the lenders
will last for more collateral so then
what happens is this is the the part
where it's it's more vulnerable the
people who borrowed so much the
leveraged buyers when the price goes
down they get completely crushed because
remember they're more sensitive to the
price a small fallen price of the asset
that when they weren't leveraged
wouldn't have made much difference to
them now if they're 30 or 40 times
leveraged they they can go bankrupt and
they get wiped out of business so I
didn't tell you before I was gonna tell
you how leveraged people were well maybe
I'll tell you later how bit leveraged
people are okay I'll tell you later okay
so the leverage guys go out of business
so in my old picture where we had the
public I mean the natural buyers and the
marginal buyer and everybody else what
happens is the prices start to go down
and these people who took out huge loans
the loans are now bigger than the value
of their assets they get these margin
calls they're they're forced to sell
they get wiped out of business
so these optimists who kept the price of
the asset high they're wiped out they're
not even there anymore
now the next class of people who don't
like the assets as much and aren't
willing to pay as much anyway they can't
borrow anymore because new borrowing is
drastically curtailed so it takes a lot
more of them to buy the same assets than
you had before so the marginal buyer
falls for three reasons the mortgage the
price falls for three reasons one
everybody including the marginal buyer
thinks it's worth less because the news
is bad
secondly the marginal buyer falls for
two reasons one these guys get wiped out
and two it takes a lot more people to
buy the assets because they can't borrow
as much anymore so the marginal buyer
sinks way down to here so the price has
gone down so far not so much because of
the bad news but because the marginal
buyer has changed and that's why the
price comes crashing down okay so the
leverage made the asset prices go much
higher than they would have ever been
without leverage then they get to be
much lower than they would have been had
there never been leveraged to begin with
and so the gap between the high price
and the high loans and the new prices is
incredibly big and so the number of
underwater businesses and homeowners can
be huge and that's the situation we're
in now so what could be a simpler theory
I mean it's almost sometimes you know if
I talk to economists they're all
skeptical I talk to you know Donna
Connors they think well what's more
obvious than that but anyway it so it's
kinda gets common sensical but all right
so the the leverage cycle you know I
think occurred recurred over and over
again I'm no economic historian but you
know in the tulip bulb craze in Holland
where they were spending you know huge
amounts of you know hundreds of acres of
land worth the tulip they weren't buying
the tulips for cash in the land boom in
Florida they were doing it all on
money and in Japan when the imperial
gardens that plot of land that size pot
of land was worth as much as California
people weren't buying land like that
with cash
they were borrowing almost all of it and
putting just a tiny bit down and then
the two crises 94 which I forgot to
write in 98 that I lived through were
leveraged cycle things and but I'm gonna
talk in detail just about this one okay
so I want to talk about that I want to
sort of document it in the current story
so this is a famous picture the green
curve and on the horizontal axis we have
2002 to the 2009 that's when I drew the
picture and on the vertical axis on the
right we have housing prices the index
formed by Shiller so this green thing is
at a hundred here in 2000 and by the
second quarter of 2006 it goes up to one
hundred ninety a ninety percent rise in
the price of housing in six and a half
years or seven years six or seven years
so Shiller deserves credit for many
things one of them is you know no one
before him developed a housing price
index it's astonishing that no one
thought that was important but anyway
it's not so obvious to do because you
know different houses get traded so he
looks for the same house that's REIT
rated and only keeps track of those and
it's complicated to explain but anyhow
he got a housing price index and he said
look my index shows housing prices have
gone up by 90 percent in six and a half
years this is incredible something's
wrong you know it's irrational
exuberance people are just crazy they've
convinced themselves that prices can
only go up and they can't go down this
is a story of irrational exuberance so
he's become famous for introducing
psychological elements into economics of
course there many other people doing it
but he's one of the most influential
leaders of psychology into economics and
I don't doubt that that's very important
but what I did is I went out in the
purple diagram I went to every home that
wasn't a government loan and half of
them aren't government loans Fannie or
Freddie half of them are you know
subprime loans all day loans jumbo loans
all those things you can find out loan
by loan what's all the mortgages that
the people own on their houses so every
month I took every house and I added up
all the mortgages on each house I had to
pay something through my hedge fund to
get this data but anyway so we found
this data
come back to that pain to get the data
we got the data and so I wrote down for
every house you know what the loan is
what's the total loans made on the house
as collateral and so then I said okay
it's surprising that many people buy
houses and put only 20% down so I said
let's look at the 50% which is you know
a huge number who are leveraged the most
so I ignore all the barely borrowing
people but I still take the top 50% and
I just average the loan-to-value for all
of them the average so clearly it's an
easy deal to get so the average
downpayment in 2000 was 14% down payment
from the top it's a loan to values 86%
it goes up extremely correlated as you
can see and hits the peak in exactly the
same month and here the peak of that
purple line is 2.7 percent down payment
so the average down payment of the top
50% so that's like mister 25% is putting
2.7 percent down there are a lot of
people putting nothing down on their
houses or you know half a percent down
and then leveraged suddenly collapses
and then you see housing prices
collapsing afterwards so my story is
that yes psychology I'm sure played a
big role but leveraged I think was the
fundamental driver it got easier and
easier to borrow money to buy a house
that's why housing prices went up and
more people could buy houses and the one
who leveraged collapsed and became much
harder to buy a house and demand started
to fall housing prices fell now of
course as housing prices are going up
I'm sure she'll was right people get
excited and they think all my going up
they're gonna go up some more blah blah
blah and so that fuels the the surge but
the thing driving it underneath I claim
is the leverage anyway that's my theory
so let's so in 2009 the San Francisco
Fed did a study of 3-2 people I guess at
the San Francisco fed they did a study
of every country and the per the gray
line is the household debt relative to
income so it's not quite leverage but
I'm a debt relative to income for every
country in 1997 and the whatever that is
Brown bar is the household debt to
income in 2007 so you can see that many
countries you know went up for a lot of
countries and went way up for some
countries like Ireland a huge
difference for some countries like
Germany and Japan it uh you know it when
hardly went up at all or went down even
so then if you look what happened to
housing prices between 1997 and 2007
that's what they did if you put it on a
graph here you say the change in
household they call it leverage it's a
different meaning of leverage where the
change in in debt to income so leveraged
let's call it of the households on the
horizontal axis between 97 and 2007 and
the change in housing prices so you look
at Ireland huge increase in debt of a
household borrowing like crazy and look
at how much their housing prices went up
now this is a different index from
Shiller so the numbers are slightly
different but anyway it's the same cents
UK huge increase in debt and huge
increase in housing prices and now look
at Germany and Japan their debt
household debt went slightly down and
their housing prices went Sennett me
down so the countries that borrowed like
crazy their housing prices went up and
the countries where they didn't borrow
the housing prices went down okay so
that's consistent with I threw then what
happened after the crisis which country
suffered the biggest losses by 2009 well
the very countries Ireland Denmark
you know Portugal all these UK the ones
that big did the big lending they're the
ones who suffered the biggest loss in
GDP and the countries like Germany and
Japan that didn't they had very minor
losses and GDP in fact Germany still
went up okay so now if you look at
leverage not just in housing but if you
look at leverage and securities you find
the same pattern so this was data that
my hedge fund collected this is the same
graph except when we borrowed to buy
mortgage securities what's the down
payment over a basket you know what are
we offered as a down payment so you can
see it was 10% for awhile then I went to
40% in the 98 crisis that was the one
where long-term capital went out of
business and then it went to 5% down 20
to 1 leverage and then in the crisis
leveraged collapses and the red line is
prices triple a crisis so these are
supposed to be the safest and best
possible bonds they're always about a
hundred and then you know after leverage
starts going down the prices start to
collapse and leverage went back up and
the prices went back
so the reason I'm showing these and I
keep mentioning data and paying for the
data is I talked at the Fed many times
now and one of the earlier talks I said
what were you doing didn't you realize
that leverage was going way up and in
this picture about housing didn't you
realize that this was happening to
leverage why didn't you do something
about it it's not an accident that
housing prices went up leverage went up
and they said well it costs you know two
to four hundred thousand dollars to get
all this data and the Federal Reserve
made a determination that it wasn't
worth the money to get all this data
before the crisis so now they're getting
the data so anyway so leverage okay
that's the story so I don't want to tell
more about okay so how did the crash
start in my opinion what was the
triggering event of the crash I realize
I'm going a little too slowly so I'll
get to the punchline here how did the
crash start it what was the event that
started it all off well some people
don't have anything to say but many
people say it's housing prices somehow
housing prices fell and you know the
banks and stuff because they gave all
these mortgages they were crushed by
falling housing prices housing prices go
down 40% what can you do the banks were
just dumb and they didn't think that
could ever happen so they weren't
prepared for it that's the standard
story but why should housing prices have
gone down so far well that's my so
remember this story it's collateral
collapsing I mean leveraged collapsing
why did leveraged collapse that's my
explanation it's not just housing prices
went down out of the blue or because
Shiller said the story changed they
started telling a pessimistic story
instead of an optimistic story I claim
something happened leverage goes down
why did it go down well the crisis began
in February of 2007 this is the subprime
mortgage index for a triple a double a
and so on and you see it's always at a
hundred it only got started in 2006 but
it's you know before that if it existed
it always be at a hundred then suddenly
in February 2007 the trip will be more
subprime mortgage index collapsed to 60
dramatic fall and went once look lower
after that but why did it fall it's
because if you keep track of
delinquencies so this is countrywide
loans remember their famous player in
the subprime mortgage lending world if
you take the
vintages of loans what would happen is
the you know depending when they started
and this is time going by the old loans
2003 delinquencies that's delinquencies
as a percentage of the original ones
they'd go up to 2% and they sort of
asymptote there some people would
default and they get thrown out of their
houses so they would disappear the
people in delinquency would stay around
2% and never get higher well that same
thing happened with 2004 and you know
but then the 2005 loans suddenly went
from 2% to 5% and the 2006 loans look
like they're headed the same way so the
quality of loans deteriorate a little
bit this was news to most people because
there had never been all these subprime
loans before we didn't know how the
homeowners were gonna these new kinds of
homeowners were gonna behave whether
they would default or not so here
there's hardly a change 2% to 5% is
nothing the subprime interest rate is so
high even a 5% default and you got
nothing back on your morgue on your
house when you sold it you'd still get
you'd make a decent return but you'd
expect 50 or 75 percent back once you
sell the house so 5% the faulting is not
a very big number it's like 10 minutes
late at the airport but everybody said
to themselves if it can go from 2% which
we expect to 5% maybe it can go much
higher which of course subsequently it
did and maybe we should be more careful
and make loans with higher collateral so
that's why the collateral suddenly came
crashing down people got more nervous
okay so that's basically and then the
prices followed so that's my story of
the leverage cycle and you're gonna see
I'm gonna add another twist to it
so I claim the same story covers almost
all the great crises and economics
they're all leverage cycle crises
they've just never been called that
before and so this one was worse than
the 98 one or the 94 one why there was a
longer period of low volatility there
was more securitization more innovation
so leverage got higher than ever before
then of course the government guaranteed
you know Fannie and Freddie and you know
and maybe implicitly the banks they were
too big to fail encourage them to
leverage more and maybe the banks were
lying but in any case all these things
put together made for much more leverage
and the interest rates were also very
low maybe people were desperate for
yield so they leveraged more the fact is
there was much more leverage than ever
before in those previous crises the
leverage was in both
Security's end housing a double leverage
cycle we never had that before
and the last the new twist I'm adding is
CD s so what our CD s you've probably
heard that word collateralized default
swaps they they allow you to there you
can if you buy a CD S on a bond and the
bond defaults you get paid it's like an
insurance on the bond okay so now who's
going to take out the insurance and the
bonds the people who are pessimistic and
think the bond price is going to fall so
it's a way of people betting on the
bonds defaulting okay and so for the
first time in this picture first time in
this picture the people at the bottom
instead of standing there in amazement
and saying all the price is way too high
I guess that we're back here instead of
saying the price is way too high and
being amazed but not being able to do
for something they could now bet against
the price so they are effectively
leveraging their pessimistic opinion
okay so that that's the second big thing
that happened the the pessimist got a
chance to leverage okay so that's why I
think that the the bad news the scary
bad news and the pessimist leveraging is
what drove the price is incredibly far
down so then once you had all these
houses and banks underwater we're in the
crisis were in now and my punchline is
gonna be how to get out of it okay so
financial innovation I'm saying
effectively helped to cause the crisis
to because there's this incredible surge
of securitization you've heard of
securitization and all these pools of
mortgages it gotten to the trillion
these are trillions of dollars a year it
got into the trick you know from nothing
to trillions of dollars of this that's
like a kind of leverage made the prices
go up and then much later than that the
CD asses got created so here I'm
starting in 2004 so the way of getting
the pessimists to bet only happened far
afterwards if you've read the big short
it's about these guys three guys and
Michael Lewis telling the story of three
people thought subprime mortgages were
overvalued but they couldn't bet against
the market until 2005 when the CD
essence got standardized and they could
bet against it so that's why all of a
sudden so you know there's financial
innovation is with no leverage then you
allow leveraged prices go up you allow
securitizations prices go up more
then you have the CD s and the scary bad
news and things go down ok so what's so
bad about I'm coming to the punchline
what's so bad about the leverage cycle
well you know when people go bankrupt
there's an externality they don't take
into the bosses don't take into account
that they're destroying their workers
lives and the businesses around them and
stuff like that and they're making other
guys go bankrupt when they go bankrupt
then when people are in debt this is the
biggest reason they don't behave well if
you're a homeowner and you owe more
money than your house is worth you're
not gonna pay to fix up your house
you're not gonna hire a gardener to fix
the garden you're not gonna add a wing
to the house you may not even make your
payment's cuz it's not your house and so
people stop economic activity you can't
take a job in another state because you
can't sell your house because you don't
have money to pay off the loan the bank
won't let you sell the house everything
grinds to a halt and if they take the
collateral as you'll see it's a huge
loss the the typical recovery on a
subprime loan after you throw the person
out of his house
you get one quarter loan back okay and
so with with lot little borrowing
there's little investment little
activity the huge amount of borrowing
allowed just a tiny fraction of people
to control the market I was going to
tell you that in 2006 at the tide of
leverage the toxic mortgage securities
were leveraged 16 to 1 that means two
and a half trillion dollars of the toxic
mortgage securities that were in the
papers all the time that meant a hundred
fifty billion dollars could have bought
with the borrowing all those securities
of two and a half trillion well Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett two people
alone had had 150 billion dollars so you
talk about the marginal buyer it could
have been there only two guys on top of
the marginal buyer fortunately those
guys weren't buying and they're saying
that maybe the people at the top are
crazy you get crazy prices and crazy
things happening so you also get a you
know and when things crash then people
are subject to too much volatility and
too much risk and also it creates a lot
of inequality when people are borrowing
and betting on things going up and
things keep going up they get richer and
richer and so inequality arises - so
there are many things wrong with the
leverage cycle but anyway what should we
do about it and here's my punchline the
first thing is we have to collect the
data the
the Fed wasn't collecting before it's
got to stop start collecting the data
which of course it is now but more
systematic it's got to regulate investor
leverage I think the Fed should actually
say you can't buy a house with 2% down
we just won't allow it many other
countries Israel the Bank of Israel
decided housing prices got too high and
the president of the Bank of Israel said
I'm passing a regulation no bank can
give more than 60 percent loan to value
on any house and so he's gonna try and
bring housing prices down by controlling
leverage we never do that we just
changed the interest rate so that's how
you stop the leverage you reg you you
monitor leverage and then you regulate
it and then once you get in the crisis
you have to undo the three things that
happen in the crisis you have to reduce
the uncertainty which is usually who's
gonna go bankrupt so clarify who's gonna
go bankrupt you have to step in and go
around the banks and lend around the
banks and and maybe you have to bail out
some of the key players who've gone out
of business but that's in the middle of
the crisis after that the most important
thing is to reduce the debt overhang
when so many people are so far
underwater and not doing anything you
have to write down principle and that's
the biggest mistake the Obama
administration began they knew from
January 2007 five years ago there was
there gonna be this underwater problem
in housing they haven't done anything
about it so just tell you how bad it is
two and a half million people have
already been thrown out of their houses
the Obama administration I feel they
think or some of them thought anyway
that the worst is over and things are
gonna get better well if you do loan by
loan you just keep track of the data
it's not complicated but you have to
look at get your fingers dirty looking
at the data there are five million more
people who are seriously where ninety
days or more delinquent they're all
going to default and be thrown out of
their houses so there's two and a half
million already there's five million
more and of the other 50 million
probably I estimate 3 to 5 million who
are still paying they're so far
underwater they're gonna default to so
we're gonna have 8 to 10 million more
households thrown out of their houses I
had to give the graduation speech at the
University of Athens this June I'm a
Business and Economics School and so I
said everyone's worried about default in
Greece they're gonna be more Americans
thrown out of their house
for defaulting then there are people in
all of Greece so we've got a so these so
all right so it's gonna be a you know if
you think the Occupy Wall Street is a
serious problem now wait till eight
million people get thrown out of their
houses so why didn't we do something
about it well what we did do was we
wrote down interest a little bit and it
didn't solve the problem now I have to
say because I'm used to all this data it
was very clear to me what was gonna
happen so I went to you know Larry
Summers I went to Bernanke I went to
everyone I could think of in the
administration and told them this and I
then I wrote about it in the New York
Times twice about how you have to write
down principle so the basic idea is this
if you the subprime lenders let's say
you have a loan for 160,000 and the
house has fallen to a hundred thousand
so it's 160 loan-to-value if you throw
the guy out of the house it'll take 18
months to three years to get them out of
the house during that time they're not
gonna pay their mortgage they're not
gonna pay their taxes they're not gonna
fix the house they're not gonna fix the
garden they're not gonna do anything and
it towards the end they'll probably ruin
the house and then you'll need a realtor
to sell it the typical lender gets back
25% at the end once the house is sold of
the original hundred sixty thousand
that's a forty thousand if you forgave
half the loan to 80,000 or 90,000 just
under the value of the house you'd
probably get the money the homeowner
would probably start paying or if he
didn't pay he'd sell the house and take
his little equity and you'd get your
eighty thousand back it would be better
for the lender and better for the
homeowner that people would stay in the
houses and if people stayed in their
houses and if everybody stayed in their
houses housing prices wouldn't fall they
go back up in fact housing prices should
be going up because we haven't built any
in four years and there's a huge upswing
and the number of young people who are
gonna start to look for houses but
housing prices keep going down because
everybody knows they're all these people
are gonna be thrown out of their houses
who haven't been thrown out yet so what
did I recommend I recommended that the
government hire these community bankers
appointed by the government paid for by
the government all the loan information
from New Haven loans should be sent to
the New Haven community bankers and
their job would be to modify the loan to
make as much money as possible for the
lender not for the borrower
and very often that would be writing
down the principal and be good for the
borrower too okay so the crisis stage of
a leveraged cycle it's always the case
you just the loans are too big nobody
could possibly expect the borrowers to
pay the loan has to be forgiven but
people just won't do that now how did I
know things we're gonna get so bad I
it's it's just simple data it's an
overwhelming evidence look at in in in
what this is the second half of 2008
over six months you look at people with
a loan combine current loan-to-value so
say take 150 or 160 and you look at the
subprime loans that's the black one 8% a
month
we're defaulting this is per month so
you knew that the people who are still
in our house is still paying 8% a month
we're gonna default it was obvious that
in a year or two they would have all
defaulted so if you wrote there and once
they're defaulting you know there's no
turning back and then it's amassing you
have you know they ruin the house and
all that so you could or someone else
ruins the house so see I knew what was
gonna happen anyone who looked at this
data could tell what was gonna happen
okay and so so why didn't they write
down the principle well I guess I should
leave this to questions but the
servicers that the bond holders in the
securitization don't have the option of
talking to the homeowners they don't
even know who the homeowners are it's
the servicer who's the banker who's got
the job of writing the letters to the
homeowner and saying pay your loan or
else we'll throw you out of the house
when they pay they the banker divides
the money up the servicer divides it up
among the homeowners but the servicers
they don't oh sorry divides the money up
among the bondholders but the servicer
doesn't own the bonds so well you know
to write down principle you'd have to
hire a bunch of people to figure out
what the houses are worth now and how
far to write it down and whether the
homeowner could really pay if he cut the
the loan in half the fee would get cut
in half
the homeowner won't even sell the house
and then he lose the fee altogether so
the servicers also own a bunch of second
mortgages and if you write down the
first mortgage you'd have to write down
the second mortgage so servicers had no
incentive to write down the principle
that's why I said you had to hire these
community bankers the you know because
the servicers the system wasn't going to
work and some of the banks many of the
banks don't want to write down the loan
because then they have to admit that the
loan which is still current in which
they are marking at a hundred is really
only worth fifty of course eventually
it's going to be worth 40 but they don't
have to admit it now so what did we do
instead we reduce the interest rate a
little bit and the latest move is to
reduce the interest rate again and so
the interest rates have you know people
if you're still underwater even if the
interest rate goes down you default so
here is 18 months after a loans interest
was written down how many what the
cumulative rida fault probability is and
you see that eight if the prints if the
inch if the coupon is that six percent
eighty percent of the people within
eighteen months have defaulted again
anyway even if you write the interest
all the way down to two percent almost
50% of the people read the fault anyway
default after it's modified eighteen
months later so writing down the
interest rate doesn't solve the problem
so in the end what does it mean in the
end we have a standard problem the
leverage cycle to high asset prices to
high debt then high debt still and low
asset prices everybody's underwater
nobody's producing the economy's
stagnant any rational lender knows he's
not gonna get his money back but people
can't forgive the debt they haven't read
Shakespeare they don't know that to
forgive is to help the lender and the
borrower and so the Germans just can't
bring themselves to forgive the Greeks
those despicable Greeks Greeks were so
reckless far be it for to reduce the
debt and here we can't reduce the debt
to the homeowners even though we know
we're not gonna get the money back
anyway so in the end the only way to get
out of the crisis is to stop yours
together the crisis is to forgive the
debt just like Shakespeare recommended